les 9h18 nous descendons dans la cave
dont la porte s'est ouverte tout seul
chez nous si tu veux communiquer avec
nous et vous êtes quoi au juste
on est chercheur en paranormal chasseurs
de fantômes mais on préfère être connus
simplement en tant que head et le renoir
end
comment
demain il ya quelqu'un qui aimerait vous
dire un mot il se passe des choses
terribles et dans la maison on est le
1er novembre 71 je suis ici avec
caroline père ans qui avec sa famille
est confronté à des événements
surnaturels tu captes quelque chose
serait une chose affreuse s'est passé
ici
qu est-ce qu il ya tout ce que lawrence
envoie touch est une épreuve très lourd
pour elle un peu plus à chaque fois je
dois vous dire qu'il ya beaucoup
d'esprit mais c'est celui là qui me
préoccupe le plus parce qu'il est très
mal faisant
regardez
il faut qu'on s'en aille d'ici ça ne
vous aidera pas cette entité
malveillantes s'est accroché à votre
salive on perd on n'a jamais vu des
choses comme celle ci
je viens avec ton non je ne veux pas de
perdre
dans mes rêves je vois une dame avec une
chemise tony tout seul elle est debout
devant le lit de ma maman
tu fais voir oui quand la musique
s'arrêtera tu verras dans le miroir ou
debout derrière toi regardez